[Música]
el mar
[Aplausos]
todos nosotros nacemos con una identidad
pero es una identidad mucho más grande
que nosotros mismos mucho más grande que
nuestros nombres que nuestros apellidos
que lo que hacemos
es una identidad que nos fue legada por
comunidades anteriores a las nuestras
es muy importante de tenerlo presente yo
por ejemplo nací en santiago de chile en
la década de los años 70 crecí en un
barrio que se llama providencia la
providencia de las torres tajamar
soy hija de una familia grande de
anticuarios padre madre tíos tías todas
anticuadas
me formé en conversaciones de arte de
cosas viejas en el barrio mapocho
tuve la fortuna de viajar con mi padre
por todo chile buscando aquellos objetos
que a lo mejor y a la gente no los
quería pero otros sí que lo encontraban
valor en esos viajes aparte de conocer
chile conocí ciertos hábitos culturales
que teníamos los chilenos y me empecé a
reconocer en ellos por ejemplo llegamos
a ciertos pueblos y siempre buscábamos
plazas y lugares donde poder comer
comida casera
entonces a temprana edad empecé a
adquirir ciertos gustos que siempre una
mesa tenía que haber un buen peor un
buen pan amasado y sobre pilas
también crecí con olores y colores
olores al campo chileno olores a la
madera vieja de los muebles antiguos
olores
del mar yo con mi papá me traía mucho en
la quinta región de esto él fue quien me
mostró la belleza de esta ciudad de
valparaíso y mis abuelos paternos
tuvieron un emporio en el cerro barón el
cual yo no conocí pero conocí sus
historias también
lo que les quiero decir con eso es que
uno pertenece a algo y lo que yo me di
cuenta es que ese algo se construye se
construye colectivamente y esa
construcción colectiva de la cual todos
somos parte
finalmente son experiencias pero también
son acuerdos
al andar de mi carrera me di cuenta que
si yo quería preservar el patrimonio a
lo cual yo me dedico para hacerlo con
éxito si efectivamente tenía que
entender cosas técnicas no es cierto en
mi propia disciplina pero tenía que
saber hacer algo que no a ninguna
universidad y que era tenía que ser una
generadora de acuerdos con personas
acuerdos con actores de mi paisaje
cultural lo que yo les narre de mi
familia es un paisaje
es un paisaje donde hay cosas que están
construidas como los barrios edificios
calles pero también donde hay cosas
intangibles como los olores los colores
y tradiciones
cuando me di cuenta que lo que había que
generar son acuerdos me di cuenta que
tenía que aprender otros talentos como
por ejemplo escuchar escuchar historias
diferentes a las mías aprender a
adquirirlas y entenderlas
tenía que aprender a seducir historias
que yo quería que se valorarán porque
tengo que construir con ellos con otros
tengo que saber acordar que quiero que
valoremos que queremos valorar para que
esos paisajes culturales sean nuestro
futuro
entonces me di cuenta que había una
dimensión del patrimonio que era letra
me más me convocaba llegar a la
dimensión política del patrimonio
cultural
que quiero decir que finalmente la
posibilidad y esta tríada de pasado
presente y futuro tiene un componente
social de una responsabilidad enorme que
a nadie debería dejar indiferente
luego el pasar de los años también si
aprendiendo otras cosas como por ejemplo
el dinamismo social que implicaba en los
paisajes culturales
llevando un poco más amplio el tema los
quiero llevar a lo que puede pasar por
ejemplo en un país como siria
en siria se congrega 16.000 años de la
historia de la humanidad 16 mil años
qué tiene que ver con todos nosotros una
de las civilizaciones en cydia yo no sé
si ustedes saben desde los años 80 hasta
hoy está con un conflicto bélico muy
importante el cual ha destruido
paulatinamente el paisaje cultural sus
tradiciones su patrimonio construido de
esto la unesco pensada ya no piensa que
es un efecto colateral de la guerra ya
lo entendieron como un foco bélico
porque
porque destruir la identidad de las
personas es lo peor que le puede pasar a
los pueblos
y piensa solamente un segundo todos
ustedes lo que es no tener identidad
piensen que a ustedes los después de sus
hábitos culturales piensen en otros
grupos más vulnerables incluso piensen
en niños los niños no solamente decir ya
no es cierto le gusta a otras partes de
países vecinos que están creciendo y
naciendo en lugares de tránsito siendo
transparentes sin referencias
piensen en los más grandes en los
agujeros a los cuales se les despojó
totalmente de todo absolutamente de
todos
entonces porque el patrimonio tiene una
dimensión política
porque tenemos que acordar las cosas
el patrimonio también es movilidad
también son personas moviéndose en esta
región siempre festejamos a los
migrantes que hicieron posible y
forjaron nuestras ciudades
ingleses alemanes
italianas
pero nosotros también nos estamos
moviendo
por ejemplo yo vivió en méxico
viví en una ciudad que se llama san
miguel de allende en el centro de méxico
una ciudad pequeña nación muy turística
colonial preciosa
yo aprendía y era chilena
pero que estaba evitando un paisaje
mexicano
entonces si bien tenía mis hábitos
culturales chilenos mi paisaje cultural
ya no estaba conmigo
y todos los días habitada con mexicana
comían sus comidas escuchar su música
que me terminaron de gustar mucho las
banderas
vivían sus tradiciones aprendí a reírme
de los chistes mexicanos que es muy
difícil
y finalmente de mexico me fui a vivir a
italia
al norte de italia una acción muy bonita
que astori no y después a venecia y ahí
ya era un poquito con hábitos mexicanos
chilena pero que no estaba en mexico que
no estaba en chile entonces vivía como
italiana
y comía su comida escucha también su
música iba a sus museos veía toda esta
majestuosidad
y chile y méxico- meta pero para siempre
cuando volví a chile decidí que no podía
volver a vivir a santiago me había
acostumbrado a una rutina de ciudades
más caminables más pequeñas me había
acostumbrado a comprar hasta la más
pequeña de mercados a mirar la fruta la
verdura la carne no quería ir más a los
supermercados
y que diga que mi familia y mis hijos
vivieron un ambiente que yo consideraba
quería valorar para ellos mejor a mi
juicio mejor
cuando vuelvo a chile y no quería vivir
a santiago decidimos vivir en valparaíso
y hoy en valparaíso desde el año 2008
y mis dos hijas son porteñas con una
mamá chilena pero un poquito mexicana un
poquito italiana mi marido veneciano
italiano pero ya un poquito chileno y
todos porteños entonces el paisaje
cultural de mi casa se construyó así por
experiencias diversas
en mi caso afectivamente no puede faltar
el partido el parmesano y el picante el
chile
entonces ese paisaje cultural que sucede
en mi casa también sucede en chile
si vamos al centro de santiago si vamos
a la calle pedro montt y vamos a
encontrar nuevas sonoridades música
colombiana venezolana nuevos olores de
nuestras comidas
algo suena
vamos a encontrar música distinta
colores de pieles diferentes
con los que les quiero decir es que los
paisajes culturales son dinámicos
yo cuando empecé
a trabajar en patrimonio había una
concepción distinta a la que hay hoy
era el concepto del patrimonio
monumental ese gran de los grandes
edificios cuya historia les dio la nos
enaltecen para que pasaran de
generaciones y generaciones no es que no
exista esa definición hoy la hay
de hecho nuestras leyes y muchos países
tienen esa orientación afortunadamente
hoy la ley de patrimonio en chile está
cambiando soy parte también o de las
comisiones de que estamos trabajando en
eso y lo interesante es que el paisaje
cultural va a ser un vector importante
en nuestra nueva ley y porque eso es
importante por la dimensión política que
les agrada
porque finalmente nosotros todos tenemos
que acordar qué paisaje cultural
queremos tener
y esas son decisiones no pasa sólo son
acuerdos son acuerdos políticos son
acuerdos comunitarios y porque es
importante saber qué patrimonio
habitamos
porque no puede ser construido por otros
tiene que ser acordado por nosotros
entonces para que tomemos buenas
decisiones tenemos que saber quiénes
somos y quiénes queremos ser
ahora
pensemos en valparaíso
miremos
el anfiteatro
yo no sé si todos saben pero hoy día es
momento de decisiones importantes en
esta ciudad decisiones que tienen que
ver cómo nos vamos a relacionar los
próximos 100 años con el mar
son súper importantes cuando lo decimos
así y hacías
esa es la pregunta
entonces hoy día hay proyectos de
expansión portuaria la ciudad está en
obsolescencia económica brutal hay
deterioro no entendemos para dónde va la
cosa
pero más allá de nuestras opiniones que
un proyecto es malo que el otro proyecto
no lo eres el punto es que tenemos que
valorizar la importancia
y acordar
qué paisaje vamos a querer y por eso a
mí me hace tanto sentido la
descentralización porque finalmente
los únicos que podemos acordar esos son
los que habitamos el paisaje cultural
no puede ser que sean otros que no
habitan nuestro paisaje que quizás no
conocen los detalles las experiencias
que si queremos valorizar nosotros tomen
decisiones
por eso es importante apoderarnos y ser
tutores de nuestro patrimonio
la imagen que está atrás mío es un
cuadro de tomás ya que sommers que un
inglés estuvo en el siglo 19 en
valparaíso precursor de nuestra pintura
chilena
en este cuadro es el antiguo muelle
valparaíso ustedes ven una costanera
abierta
pues si se fijan bien hay mujeres
elegantes caminando son mujeres inglesas
con sus paraguas
si se fijan bien también hay personas
descalzas
hay geografía tras la cirugía de los
cerros
los barcos esta es una foto que
un siglo pasado quiso tener hubieron
acuerdos
cuyo idiosincrasia que llegó a eso entre
personas distintas con experiencia de
todos los mundos y decidieron tener ese
paisaje
la pregunta es entonces quiere
responsabilidad y cuál va a ser el
paisaje que nosotros queremos tener en
100 años las muchas
[Música]
ah